well the russian invasion has changed
the way many germans view their military
and the country's security during the
cold war germany was on the front line
between east and west and boasted a much
larger military national service was
compulsory for all males but that was
abolished more than 10 years ago now
some germans believe the country could
be under threat again under stepping up
to train as reservists in the german
army
marching in step to the shooting range
they may look like pros but for ana
celindria it's all new
the clerk for logistics management is
training to become a reservist here at
the clause of its barracks in northern
germany
it's quite exciting to actually hold a
weapon
i had never shot a rifle before and so i
was quite nervous
however we were very well prepared we
did quite a few dry runs so that we'd be
ready
and they're not just trained to shoot
but also given medical training and
taught military law
among the 61 recruits public service
employees engineers and electricians
average age 37
they're deemed highly motivated and will
later be used in homeland security
for the head of lower saxony state
command these recruits are welcome
reinforcements
after decades of specializing in
missions abroad the german armed forces
are now turning their focus on national
and collective defense again
we need to master the use of combined
arms again
we also need to handle germany's
responsibility as a hub
if reinforcements on behalf of the nato
alliance are sent to germany in order to
be deployed to another country
and the bundeswehr has to carry out
those services as part of the so-called
host nation support
those are duties that we have not been
attending to quite so closely
however they're now gaining in
importance again
and because of that forces have to be
trained just like these reservists here
today
for a long time germans weren't too
interested in their military in fact
many viewed it rather skeptically
russia's invasion of ukraine has changed
that and increased the importance of the
bundeswehr as well as the motivation of
these future reservists
at first i really was a bit scared i was
like do i still really want to do this
but i'm increasingly convinced that our
freedom and democracy are extremely
deserving of protection and i can do my
part here
and the others will do 18 days training
in total squeezing it in around their
normal jobs but once it's over they will
be ready to defend their country if the
worst comes to the worst